uh I was I had a very brief engagement
with Dr Usama alazami uh he's a um a
prominent Muslim academic um from Oxford
a very polite and respectful engagement
and I only know of him from others to be
a lovely brother and I asked him
squarely I said what are your thoughts
on Hamza Yu's statements on number one
gay sex isn't a SIN number two that he
can't change what's in scripture and
also on the following policies that he's
unequivocally advocating for pro LGBT
curriculum in primary school should be
taught young as to children as young as
five nor to conversion therapy by the
way conversion therapy brothers and
sisters is when someone is a homosexual
or identifies as a gay or lesbian that
Hamza y said he will ban criminalize any
kind of Da or n or any therapy to bring
them back to
heterosexuality so that means in
Scotland if a Muslim father his child
has become a homosexual an IM or
Community leader or a therapist cannot
bring them back into or let them realign
or consider coming back to becoming a
heterosexual he's going to criminalize
that an abortion rights right up to
birth so killing up to birth up to birth
so does that mean like an eight-month
old you take out yeah yes so he supports
this yeah openly he say this it's
unbelievable so Dr USI he goes in as
much as he says does these things he's
obviously sinful believing that gay sex
is not sinful in Islam is obviously kuur
but it's possible to interpret his words
to avoid calling him a cir I'm just
holding the well-known distinction
between General and
specific is that is that a private
message or a public no no there a public
it's a public yeah yeah well I mean as I
say um to what extent are you willing to
hold that position because if you hold
that position to its logical extreme
like someone saying that I am your lord
most high or I believe in Jesus as God I
believe in whatever so long as they have
uttered the shahada before that then you
can't make the ly cannot make te and the
question would be then is the Ley sinful
for making te on such a person I think
what's happened is that because of the
Isis situation Isis and teiri movements
people have been reluctant to make Tak
at a level that probably unprecedented
in was is Isis Syria 20 they want to be
linked with that they they know that
people link techism and they link or
teir in general with takfirism or
takfirism and violence but there's also
the incident where aani shopkeeper was
killed by someone because the person who
killed him professed the love
foram Do you hear about this incident no
yeah so there was AED shopkeeper who was
killed and um the person who killed him
wrote a letter and he identified as a
Sunni U obviously we had the murder of
the MP Joe Cox we had the by a far-right
individual we had the murder of David
aress uh by a person who identified as a
Muslim so I think the concerns are
coming from there all right so let's
let's make this very clear making te of
someone Okay and like for example my
techar of Hamza yusu is absolutely not
um a call to violence in fact we we we
would consider someone doing violence to
this person to be a sinful act in and of
itself because of the detriments the
societal detriments it would would have
and because no one's a here no one's a
judge during execution we're living in
the west you know uh which actually is
very important because when people think
about they automatically think I can be
the judge of this or someone who
pronounces of someone's a feta to kill
them this is absolutely not the case
okay so we make if if one makes it very
CLE there's a distinction between
removing someone from the fold of Islam
which we all are entitled to do as
Muslim people otherwise L our religion
become like Christianity where you can
have gay priests saying that we you know
I'm speaking on behalf of God and so on
and with the rainbow uh dog color and so
on we can't have that in our religion we
won't have that in our religion but it
seems like we're we're we're edging
towards that the prophet sallam told us
That You Will
Follow That You Will Follow The Way of
the Jews and the Christians inch by inch
arms length by arms length such that if
they go into a hole a L's hole you'd
follow them in there as well what we are
seeing with um in America and Canada and
even in the UK I was privy to my own
studies when I was learning in Oxford
University of Oxford I was in the
Anglican Church of England Church it is
absolutely fine to be to believe in
homosexuality is moral and to and to be
a practicing homosexual clergy person
yes it is absolutely in fact I would go
as far as to say OPP opposition to that
is not fine anymore in the Church of
England it's not and of course the
Church of England is just like Muslim
there are Spectrum so there are people
more conservative there are people more
but I'm saying this is what has happen
now with the church of England I can
tell you this firsthand
experience do you do we really want to
see Islam go into that direction do we
really want to see Islam become like
sorry to say North America has is is is
behind us in this regard because if
people
like people
like and others they have been allowed
to bro can you imagine the discussion we
were having maybe some time ago I was
had discussion with it's on the public
record and the discussion I was having
with him was to do with whether or not
he would even condemn her for her belief
y forget
about the discussion was whether or not
she would be condemned for believing in
lgbtq um transgender stuff and would
should be condemned and he said no the
Mas you heard what he said and he even
told us you know in the UK you've got
nothing to do with the US kind of like
I'm paraphrasing you've got nothing to
do with the US and now he's commenting
on the UK by the way the same person
he's making a big thread about the UK
and others and others but I'm saying
that y this whole idea of stay out of
our which is nonsense I me me you both
know this is nonsense but the idea of
stay out of the US he's now commenting
on the UK but the issue is look what's
happening in the US I went to ikna
Convention it's the biggest I think it's
the biggest of It kind y y if not it's
the second the first or the second
there's a lot of people there there ik
the RIS between those two yeah and there
was tens of thousands of Muslims there
it was shocking actually I've never seen
many Muslim Western Muslims in one
place and bro bro like was in that
conference no one condemned her in that
conference when I came back I realized
that I didn't even know she was in the
conference W I didn't even know when I
came back I had to make her statement of
condemnation that you know who's who's
this they're letting her in the reason
why they're letting her in is because of
this mus card because once again we go
back to the mus this assimilation
gradualism
policies the the first question is to
the Muslim Brotherhood in in the in the
west is who's given you the permission
to make decisions on our behalf that we
are okay with this kind of thing who's
given you permission the the reason why
a lot of them are upset bro is simply
because we've decided not to accept the
narrative anymore and what the reason
why I did this really quickly is because
now look at what we're discussing
whether or not he's a Muslim we're not
discussing whether or not his policies
are good for Muslims or whether he
should be condemned or not that's that's
now that goes without saying yeah do you
see what I'm trying to say it's has had
the net impact of moving the goalpost
from discussion of whether or not I mean
he put out a a post talking about you
know I I believe in this and I believe
in that you know it's a good thing and
he doesn't say it's a good thing but
yeah you can you see his post on
Facebook 95% of the people were
commenting on his post without any
exaggeration condemned
him many of them put the video of me
saying you know take fear of him but 95%
of his own followers condemned him and
they were
making the lay people making from abak
andar and this and that they were making
they was telling him we're not taking
this anymore BR I just want to say
something just just want to Echo that
point anyone who says because we had
Zara Muhammad from the Muslim Council of
Britain come onto Sky News and said that
she spoke on behalf of Muslims here by
the way bro she said uh Muslims are
ecstatic with excitement and awe upon
his appointment how dare you come on
live
TV as a representative of all Muslims in
Britain to say that we are in awe and
excitement about the appointment of
Hamza YF exactly you could have said the
Muslim Council of Britain are in
excitement and in order but you chose to
speak on behalf of Muslims and if you
see the online conversations and the
offline conversations because alhamd the
conversations that we've been having the
the relevant noise the necessary noise
that had to be
made no one is in excitement and all
there might be some elements of those
who subscribe to that level of thinking
or that type of ideology or methodology
to attain power but from what I'm seeing
the public opinion the Muslim public
opinion on these specific issues has
been overwhelmingly against ham are very
critical and that's what I find ironic
about the liberal aspects or the liberal
segments from the Muslim Brotherhood
movement is because they're not taking
account to account What Muslim people
actually want on the Grassroots even
even though in the Muslim countries they
talk about democracy for example but
look at look at all of the for example
I've had conversations with hanis the
obis the BR bro yeah course the may take
fear of him the dianis may take fear of
him the Sala may take fear of him the
may take of this guy and or a lot of
them the majority you'll find that's the
majority opinion among the the Learned
men of of these places but these
brothers who are affected by or have a
membership in an informal membership or
a formal one of the Muslim Brotherhood
it's affecting their policies that's why
I think it's happening no a a
representative of that movement's not
here so in their absence I will posit
the following to you yes we are a Muslim
minority living in the west we are
living in a hostile environment where
islamophobic hate crimes are on the
increase there are people that want to
you know change not just change our
religion there are people that want to
attack us kill us ship us away kick us
out of their countries oppress us for
draconian policies surely surely it's a
no-brainer to have a Muslim who
identifies outwardly as a Muslim would
be a better person to be in power yeah
for the betterment and the safety of our
rights than someone who's a non-muslim
or potentially someone who's right
leading and quite open about the
islamophobia which wasn't even the case
with Kate FES and Hamza YF but that is
generally what they'll posit that sadik
Khan was better than Zach gold smith
that any of the 17 Muslim MPS are better
than the non-muslim MPS that Hamza YF is
certainly better than Cape Forbes for
the Muslims yeah I mean tell us how
because he's not putting forward the
policies that we want to see as Muslim
people